ma conférence Donald Trump l'échevin dit 80
un électrochoc Paul est américain satiné
Oh non famine d'avocat donc non pris en charge
élection du système d'exploitation malade moi ma de la Papa
publicy Trump le républicain sur G a besoin d'
un ennemi logistique la démocrate Jennifer
external dit aux concessionnaires dans un
républicain Barbara  Comstock aime Jones
s / pdf si je suis tellement à gauche qu'il y a un
manque de respect pour les femmes venant de
l'administration et et je pense que beaucoup
de femmes ne vont
plus tolérer cela
et je pense que la seule façon  nous allons
changer le récit à Washington
change qui nous renvoyons leur ok généralement
démocrate sur DeKalb à Trump,
il est un embarras mondial et je veux dire
que sincèrement s'il vous plaît ouais donc certains
Dini s'entendent est-ce que je suis dégoûté
je suis dégoûté  à propos de la modélisation que
nous voyons pour nos enfants les
conversations la lat l'abaissement du
discours sur la décence et le respect contre les
femmes contre les personnes de couleur contre à
peu près tous ceux qui sont asthmatiques s  o pour
citer un démocrate musaka formidable a déclaré
candide et si présent encierro Congrès
le système d'armure pour offrir la preuve
spécialement républicain sera toujours le
Donald Trump leur maison beaucoup plus je
pense que c'est un grand président
je pense qu'il n'a aucun sens je pense qu'il
sait ce qu'il  veut qu'il ne le fasse pas il a une
sacrée colonne vertébrale il est un
président fantastique Je voterais certainement pour
lui encore
Allah Allah Allah Haymarket s'est produit
district Nomura cette nouvelle républicaine
chaque homme sur un faux voir c'est une
accusation agression contrôle sexuel ISM
cette chose avec  les femmes sont
incontrôlables en blâmant les hommes pour tout, je
pense juste que nous devons arrêter cela va vraiment
blesser les femmes à long terme
Bach a dit généralement les gens que vous pouvez L pour les
juifs le vrai chef De La Maison
Blanche Isis agit vous savez je suppose et
je  pensez dans le cas de Trump à la façon dont l'
économie est en plein essor et offre des
opportunités à des personnes qui n'avaient jamais eu
cela auparavant, y compris les femmes, c'est une grande
victoire pour nous
kombucha So  lem popularité Trump paganel
moi Malte so Santa Marta of eugenie
plaisir Bonneville Rapoport
directeur du couvent Suzanne citron Estrela démocrate
DiPietro NASA mérite une implication
elección alpha-2 juste bonne ville
Republika la galerie Louvois comme nous
ne pouvons pas nous asseoir et ne rien faire
parce que nous '  J'aurai toujours le
contrôle républicain du Congrès et c'est pour vous
c'est extrêmement effrayant ouais ouais
Peron vous donne le vertige Rita Vuitton ovando
palapa Yahshua a dit John nom de famille
polype Lima le divisionnaire soit un détail confortable
qui ne plaît qu'à IDO vous votez pour John
pouvons-nous compter sur votre soutien  pour avoir peur
je n'ai aucun respect pour lui je n'ai aucun
respect pour ce qu'il fait dans ce
pays je pense que le plus effrayant
c'est qu'il divise le pays bien
franchement je pense que les femmes sont
énervées nous sommes juste en colère tu sais que nous sommes  en colère
et quelqu'un d'autre m'a dit que le
professeur de l'université de palma
soi-disant élection Donald Trump en
détail au démocrate et à la majorité
grise i  si nous ne renversons pas la maison, nous
n'aurons pas de contrôle sur certaines des choses
que cette administration fait
oloppor republicanos Oh fu Zi comme dire à
la loco vous voyez beaucoup été évalué s'il
vous plaît votre console que je préfère non un Diwali
love hula oz mama les gens craignent
que si leur scène est conservatrice, cela
puisse avoir un impact sur leur travail, leur famille pourrait
être bouleversée par le marché Oh contraire oke
ofr so new position Donald Trump evil
república de su casa la la J'ai
délibérément interdit Estelle Lebovitz
alors s'il vous plaît venez rarement  à l'intérieur de 92 millions de
personnes en Amérique n'ont pas voté à l'
élection présidentielle et cela s'est réveillé
le lendemain matin et nous avions quelqu'un que
beaucoup d'entre nous ne s'attendaient pas à être président,
je pense que beaucoup de gens ont reconnu que
je devais faire plus Donald Trump  une
blonde de Lomenzo une tsundere donne une feuille je suis donc -
Shelly démocrate pas de pilote sur des tirs à un
gardien critique en évolution - Angela
personnage politique numériquement la sœur
Barbara Portia
Isaac est revenue